foreign
[Music]
addressing supporters outside the
headquarters of the justice and
development party in Ankara
was his first appearance since the polls
closed he told them he's ready for a
runoff
seeing that the margin with the close
-honent is more than 2 million votes and
with the final result we will see a
wider margin if our nation has decided
to go to a second round we will respect
that decision
his main Challenger Kamal khalistarolu
leads a six-party opposition Alliance
that's determined to unseat erdogan he
urged his supporters to be patient
despite his smear campaign against us
erdogan hasn't gotten the result he
wanted if the first round wasn't enough
to receive the Mandate we are going to
get it in the runoff election election
officials have been counting the votes
throughout the night third presidential
candidate sinan owan has done better
than expected analysts say he has the
potential to be king maker one is an
anti-immigrant anti-refugee candidate
and I think it's basically a new Epoch
in Turkish politics because both sides
will Court him to get his votes and they
will have to do at least something to
satisfy his base and his message
so far owan is refusing to back either
erdogan or
kilistice
there will be another difficult 15 days
ahead of us and during this time if the
elections are completed with the current
results and go to the second round we
will do our best to make this process a
good one for our nation and our country
at this time we are not saying that we
will support one party or the other
erdogan has led turkey for two decades
overseeing growth in trade and foreign
investment as well as ambitious
infrastructure development projects but
more recently he's been criticized for
high inflation and the Turkish lira's
devaluation to the U.S dollar
[Applause]
says he wants to reform the system of
governance and return power to
Parliament a runoff vote will now be
needed to decide turkey's future Sami
zaidan Al Jazeera Istanbul
we've got two correspondents in turkey
has been following